the biggest games of the year is out
today certainly a massive game if you're
an xbox one owner and one of the big
exclusives coming at this year halo 5
Guardians out finally today by the
stands were Mike a lot of people are
playing an online right now yeah there's
a bunch of people i was playing
throughout the day we had pre-release
playlists yeah and it would took a
little bit to get into war zone and
arena matches but today was I don't
think I waited longer than 10 seconds to
get in cool point your review is going
live at three o'clock in about 30
minutes yeah we're gonna give away the
score or here though life but before we
do that and talk to me a little bit
about the idea of the provisional review
obviously there was a provisional review
up on gamespot on sunday would ever
score with our final thoughts and what
was the idea behind that yeah so a lot
of times with multiplayer shooters or
just any kind of multiplayer game that's
going to be based around a lot of
servers we just we didn't want to do a
disservice to readers by publishing a
score and everything and having opinions
on it because I could have had the best
time ever in multiplayer but yeah if it
doesn't work for a week or two after
launch then what's the point you can't
get in so we want to make sure well i
provided some thoughts and everything in
the but we want to keep it brief my
review the actual review is much more in
depth of course so we just want to make
sure the servers were up cuz the embargo
is a day before release why she so not
the entire public so like australia like
and new zealand had the game before us
and gear up and everything so we want to
make sure once the servers are at their
peak yeah working if it's all working
especially i remember this time last
year having conversations with chris
waters who ended up belaying the master
chief collection yeah view I think we
didn't score that game for two weeks
until it came out yep alright put us out
of our misery halo 5 Guardians like my
hearty what did you give it given eight
out of 10 8 a 10 yep alright we talked
to you about it last week with the
campaign stuff a little bit obviously
you're a massive halo fan even you
played every single game and what is it
you like about the multiplayer what what
is it that sort of you because i know
that campaign stuff will get through a
little bit you weren't super super hot
on there but the most para stuff what is
it about thought that really sold it to
sure so I in my opinion this is the best
halo multiplayer has ever been oh yeah
you know like halo 2 sparked Xbox Live I
don't think it'd be where it is now
Freeman for halo 2 and I played you know
cat and mouse cat Mouse on Blood Gulch
back in the day in Halo 2 all the time
SWAT when they first start bringing it
out played a lot of Halo 3 multiplayer
for I it was actually like I think I
share the sentiment of a lot of people
forward is my least favorite thing 343
had a good effort with multiplayer I
like their campaign for for the most
part but you know they introduced the
call of duty kind of progression when
you get experience then build your
loadouts where there is a new
progression in Halo 5 but in arena like
the classic just team slayer capture the
flag SWAT playlists it's classic halo
our weapons are scattered throughout the
map you're starting with assault rifle
pistol in most modes and you know you
everybody's starting on equal playing
field kind of before that at least like
it's weird that that's fresh considering
that's kind of the way halo always was
but yeah it's it is fresh because
everything else old r 2 or something
yeah just a classic shooter kind of feel
and control yeah and yet you they'll
tell you their spawn timers for yeah you
know the power weapons rocket launch of
the sniper a plasma caster which is new
and I really like that because both
teams will see like this 11 nights so
you're like alright we're going for that
but [ __ ] so are they it's interesting
like even though the Reno shooters are
coming back unreal tournament was the
exact same thing and really shows you
how much is left oh yeah it creates
these awesome clash points where
everybody's just fighting over the
rocket launcher and then of course
someone gets it and blows up half your
team on accident just happened to me but
yeah the multi it feels awesome cuz
arena is irie is great but one of my
favorite parts about halo 5 and just
something i think is really fresh for
the shooter genre in general is war zone
the new mode and it's it's very MOBA
inspired and i'm not a big mobile player
but i see their merit and I understand
why people follow them so closely there
is just this great blend of PvE and PvP
combat so this is this replaces big team
battle playlist which a lot of people
were kind of pissed about it first but I
once I played war zone it erased any
doubts I had really um so you you do
have a progression system but you'll
start off there are three capture points
and then both teams have a core so kind
of the fortress and MOBAs okay you can
take these capture points and those let
you spawn across the map in more places
you get these wreck consoles to call in
power weapons vehicles but you can also
shoot a I like right here there's
Prometheans guarding this oh so it's
like in titanfall or something it's like
the minions orla creeps I frico and you
get the you compose and they contribute
you can see at the bottom here there's
energy meter that's your currency pretty
much throughout the mathematic builds up
to i think in maximum nine which I've
never hit how many humans are on either
team it is a minimum of nine versus nine
but it can be up to 12 verses 12 okay
thanks and there's what there's raid
which is just you know capturing there's
a salt which is just capturing the three
neutral zones and then destroying the
core but the classic warzone rate is my
favorite because you there's it's not
just killing other human or AI and
taking capture points every once in a
while a boss will spawn oh wow with a
weapon AI boss whether it's a regular
boss which is worth 25 points or a
legendary boss which obviously as the
name implies they take more to kill but
they're worth 150 points and both teams
are just pretty much racing to a
thousand points ok so these bosses
aren't affiliated with a one or the
other team they're neutral okay um so
that's also kind of like the power
weapons were just talking about there'll
be a legendary boss and it's just like a
mobile where the team that gets the last
hit to drain the hell fart gets it
kidding me today oh yes so taking for my
death today we're watching and there's a
legendary boss and idle railgun which is
really powerful water and I was theirs I
was just crouching so they couldn't see
me on the motion so he's just waiting I
was waiting three guys are shooting at
him in all the Sun was like oh and I
kill him the railgun and I know that
they're all pissed Oh wearing everything
they killed me right after but I got 150
points they got one for excellence and
so there that's the the great thing
about war zone like I was I was up I was
down today like 700 points to 300mm and
you know in most cases that's you're
screwed yeah but then we got a legendary
kill we capture a few more points to
start getting more spawns we we all
started spotting scorpion tanks and we
started we still lost but we're only by
like 60 points oh wow which is 60 kills
or two legendary kills one of the sort
of I guess linchpins of the Halo
franchise has always been the fact that
this was a first person shooter which
really integrated vehicles into its
combat incredibly well like even the you
know the first first game you know there
are so many levels that we still
remember today and what's it like in war
zone with the weapon with the vehicles
do they feel like they're just power-ups
in it or do they feel like they're like
a tactical aspects of the game players
very much technical aspect you can once
you can either spend your energy at the
bottom those five green this looks like
whoever gameplay this is I think it
might be Rob's whoever you spend those
on power weapons weapons power-ups like
over shields
or like in camouflage but you can also
get vehicles and then that's where it
comes in because you can get a scorpion
and that will help you take out a
legendary boss but then someone a of the
team could just easily call in a rocket
launcher if they have rocket launcher
cards to burn through and take you out
so it's very balanced like despite the
fact that you can call in a scorpion
tank there's always just these like
checks and balances in the requisition
system which is a hold that's the
progression system which you could talk
about that for a while too but it's very
balanced but at the same time vehicles
yet can turn the tide of a battle just
just as easily as you know killing a
legendary box will talk about the combat
in a second but first of all another
aspect that we didn't really get to talk
about much last week with co-op how does
that work how many people can play and
what's it like so you can play up to
four people you know people got kind of
upset when they heard you can't play
split screen co-op yeah which I agree
with I love that but playing four player
co-op in the campaign it runs very
smoothly and I think you know they
focused a lot on making the online
experience smooth and the result is
really smooth you get the campaign's
pretty much structured like people who
played halo 2 will feel a little
familiar but that you bounced between
when they you bounced between the master
chief and the arbiter of course this is
sort of the same thing except you're
bouncing between team Osiris which is a
bunch of Spartan fours led by agent
Jameson Locke who was introduced in a
nightfall like its canonical but it's
not in the games then you have blue team
which is Master Chief and three of his
Spartan tues who were in like you know
the books I used to read but you each in
each of the Spartans has their own
separate loadouts so you know Fred will
start with a DMR and a pistol chief will
start with assault rifle and pistol like
the classic one you know lock has a
battle rifle but you they all have like
certain character traits that kind of
contribute to how they they don't really
play differently but um you know like
Kelly can run a little faster Fred can
take a little more damage chief shields
recharge little faster this is rob about
to punt this grunt there havel veterans
will remember the grunt birthday party
skull yeah when you when you turn it on
it's just any time you get a grunt
headshot they pop into confetti and
there's no yeah of course yeah and
that's how you get it you punt that
grunt off the side yeah so this is Jake
Rob Eric and I apply
a four-player and is it is it more fun
do you think playing co-op than it is oh
absolutely for a few reasons because
there are a lot of branching the new
level design of the campaign which
gameplay wise the campaign is awesome i
love it you can you can kind of see
their these wide open areas they're more
like these arenas or sand boxes than
these linear pathways yeah which I was
kind of apprehensive about because i
liked the linearity of halo it felt like
they were funneling me through certain
areas and kind of designing it to be a
certain way but you can replay these a
second time and it'll be very different
cuz you'll crash through this wall and
you'll find a like go serve vehicles
that you didn't know about before or
there's there's a mission early on like
the third mission or something when Rob
played it and he didn't know that you
could turn on these auto turrets that
help you like six of these huge gattling
turrets and I like stumbled on it yeah
and then I played it completely
differently and I let those do the work
but co-op you can kind of split up and
say you take the few rock in you take
the Scorpion I'm going to get in this
Phaeton cover you guys from the air it's
really fun and it also negates the AI
which ranges from remarkably good to
abysmal okay which is you know it's I've
always imagined my girl right yeah I
imagine that my review that it's
inconsistent AI ya so if you get down
this is the first halo in the campaign
where you can you just get down and can
get revived hmm and if you're playing
single player or to play or 33 is always
interesting cuz you have that one AI who
everybody's just really worried about ya
or if you're playing with Eric hey
everybody's worried about him 90 days
gonna heley um you'll be playing and
then you'll say hey come get me and then
instead of two like in co-op you can say
YouTube keep shooting cover us I'll go
get him yeah for sure and then an AI you
know they'll be like she runs up to you
gets killed then you'll call for help
again it's a train of like ride
sidesaddle gears of war one problem yeah
you know maybe you know pre half-life
co-op software yeah it kind of doesn't
make it as fun an experience yeah and so
yeah much more fun play co-op then
absolutely it's very fun play code yeah
it sounds like you're talking about a
game that is you know to not use the old
reviewers adage of fans of the series
will definitely get behind head 05 but
what was it about the game even as a fan
of the series yourself that stopped it
from crawling up towards the wonderful
reaches of nines and tens sure so aside
from the AI which I which I mentioned as
a negative my review because it can get
pretty coin at times
the the story which halo 4 4 as boring
as I thought the campaign was the
gameplay the story actually really like
they focus more on characterization with
a chief and cortana because Cortana is
like his only friend real like a side
Judum of three Spartans but these three
like you know teammates more than
friends yes colleagues yeah counter them
social friend partners and Pisces fine
yeah but partners and combat evolved
exactly price's with pisces and five
reversed that and i love the campaign
and the game plan it feels so great
especially the new Spartan maneuvers
wish we could talk about if you want but
yeah the story is bad the plot is very
disjointed and broken they're a bunch of
cutscenes between missions that they
fade to black before I actually three
times dou the campaign the first time I
played it like three times I remember
counting I thought I accidentally
skipped a cutscene over a dive like
moving the controller a pressing start
or something which was disappointing
because I love the story of halo I read
all that I'm a halo geek every other one
side books yeah halo fall of reach is
like one of my favorite sci-fi books and
but these cutscenes just end they'll
devote and they waste their time with
them too or they'll devote 30 seconds to
this AI just ranting about something
really inconsequential instead of
telling you why you're going to this
planet you're on so the missions lose a
lot of impact because I don't know
what's going on which you know like it
sounds negligible but if they tell a
good story surrounding missions they can
make like add a lot of momentum and
impact to these missions that you're
playing which is something that's
happened in like at least the first
three heddo games which felt like you
know its your right people will say that
that's sort of like a flippant aspect to
it but the parts in the old Halo games
that had bad parts stories people still
remember as being irritating so for that
to be continuous throughout the campaign
yeah obviously where's where's I a bit
yeah and I i remember i still never when
they first introduced the flood in halo
one at the moment where you go into that
room you see all these dead Marines but
then you watch the recording of that
same room you're in from like a few
hours before yeah and you see the flood
attack and then you cut back to the real
time you're like holy [ __ ] that's this
room that's an awesome way to tell a
story because you're still in the story
but they're not it's not you know it's
showing and not telling you this game
they try
they try too much talent yeah and they
they just don't the cutscenes don't
provide any contacts and contacts for
what you're doing and also any story
that's told in the game there's a lot of
audio logs you can pick up which I
appreciate that adds to the backstory
but it's such a the gameplay of the
campaign so you know momentous and it
keeps pushing you forward but those slow
it down and also you have to stand near
them the first time you get them to
actually hear them alright and you can
go back in them like review them in the
main menu but you have to stand next to
them and you have just wait around to
listen to them and then also there'll be
a lot of actual main like the main
narrative like the audio logs from the
ward in this character that comes into
it just other teammates will play over
that so you can't really hear not only
what you just found but also what is
being told you that just should be
essential to the plot rice and then
there also a few these missions that are
combat free and I say their missions
because you go to the menu it says
there's 15 i think but really there's 12
missions because these other three are
these kind of like RPG ish towns ok yeah
which at first I was very confused I was
it was the first time i've ever played a
halo mission without shooting anything
yeah she makes me sound like originally
it was an RPG it was a well as a
strategy game yes right and you go
around these towns talking these people
and they their dialogues well written
but it slowed it down I just don't think
it fits in this game at all and there
they really three times yeah 11 is the
same area just coming back through it to
talk to Katherine Halsey and there is
back story I think it just could have
been told in cutscenes but these
cutscenes are tough to make they look
awesome i'm sure that's no small deal to
make them but it's some orcs um yeah the
campaign story stuff wasn't super fun
the coop having i guess some some rough
around the edges AI and then of course
the these weird little or PG but apart
from the campaign stuff multiplayer
ultimate ocular and the campaign like
don't let me deter you from playing it's
fun yeah because the Spartan abilities
you can ground pound you can smash you
can you know people can split up there's
one mission where there's two people in
the faith on so ships covering the two
on the ground which we have a video of
it that video we're showing of Rob Eric
Jake and I that's that mission they're
all really fun to throw Spartan moves
transfer over to the multiplayer yeah oh
yeah and they can they're not essential
to being great but if you want to get
good at halo there's people that are
already using him really well actually I
saw Rob killing I think two people one
of the ground stop oh it's
it's tough to pull off you have to
charge it up but you have any of the
running sprints mash now and then you
have the dash which is just this quick
jetpack like a modern advanced warfare
and kind of and I was kind of
apprehensive about that too but like
some of us should be shooting me I'll
just start around a corner or get away
from a grenade or even some with an
energy sword like I'm rattling these off
because there's so many way it opens up
so many new options and I'm not used to
them but the more I play on the more I'm
kind of super on board with all of them
yeah and the halo games always you know
have a lot of options in terms of
gameplay so I guess last thing to talk
about and campaign multiplayer we've
talked about at all for just coming
later this year december last I heard
yeah it's not at release now um they've
been showing a lot of cool things too
I've actually never I've created stuff
back when you used to play on Griff
Griff ball okay 30 it's called it's like
there was kind of like rocketing ball
with gravity hammers okay driving cars
when I remember when I first played
rocky league I'm like this reminds me of
that and I did create maps I never use
it too much but there there's always a
wealth of options there I'm sure once
that comes out there will be more maps
in the arena and arena play lessons of
people like sometimes Bunji Bunji you
used to promote them 343 I'm sure might
do the same thing like really good user
created maps they'll put them into
playlists throughout each week and
feature users which I'm looking forward
to that because there are some very
smart people out there making maps for
sure that little five percent of
creators that make everything else for
the rest of a thang after them yeah
thanks so much Mike's coming on telling
us all about halo yeah 5 Guardians